[Music]
hi
mystery recapped here today i'm going to
explain a chinese comedy fantasy film
called ri chang huanjiang jinon
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
the protagonist of the movie is a con
artist named ajen
at the beginning of the movie he steals
a historic statue from a well-secured
museum the statue has several
superstitions attached to it as people
believe that whoever has owned it in the
past has gone crazy in one way or the
other after successfully getting his
hands on the said valuable zhen goes to
meet his business partner brother hey he
sells him other prehistoric things that
he has collected in the museum but keeps
the statue to himself brother haye's
client adam is furious that he didn't
get the statue later at night jen is
trying to start his car when he notices
that a car on the other side of the road
is slipping downhill as he tries to stop
it lightning strikes him and knocks him
out a flashback of his childhood shows
us that when he was little his principal
had punished him for stealing money from
his wallet although it was a prank set
by his friends jen was humiliated in
front of the entire school
that day in a fit of rage he had asked
god to hit him with lightning if he had
stolen the money back in the present he
wakes up in his bed to his surprise the
veins on his arms have turned red and
prominent zhen doesn't think much of it
and opens the fridge at first glance he
sees someone's face inside it but when
he looks again it's gone
similarly after he pees the toilet turns
into a human and starts talking jen is
beyond surprised he walks out of the
washroom but hears his couch talking
even his cat asks him to get him a
female cat soon all the objects in his
room including his tv plants decorations
and his thirsty cat start to talk jen
quickly packs up the valuable statue and
runs outside he sees a man peeing in his
car and scolds him but the man turns out
to be a stray dog
jen starts to believe that the lightning
strike to his head has made him go
insane he hurriedly gets into his car
and drives away in a rush some seconds
later his car turns into an old man and
asks him to drive slowly he sits beside
jen in the front seat smiling at him jen
stops the car and runs to a beach
holding the bag that has the statue in
it when he opens the bag the statue
talks to him the human form of the
statue comes to life and calls jen out
for stealing him following that zhen
goes to the doctor to get his head
checked the doctor just so happens to be
the principal who once accused him of
stealing his money when the doctor
refuses to believe that jen can talk to
things and animals his computer turns
into a human and talks to zhen
using the computer zhen tells the doctor
about all the promiscuous movies that
are saved on his hard drive the doctor
is left stunned now that the guy knows
that he is a pervert the doctor suggests
that he go to a psychiatrist as jen is
leaving the doctor's office he bumps
into his childhood crush and friend wang
kaume she recognizes him instantly and
the two chat for a short time zheng asks
her about any disease that may cause
people to talk to objects kaomei
suggests bath salts she only laughs at
him and gives him her card after the
brief encounter jen's mood has gotten
exponentially better he asks his car to
talk to him but it refuses some minutes
later it stops in the middle of the road
when zhen goes out to check the engine
explodes sending him flying to the
ground
somehow the statue is landed safely on
the road the human form appears and
tells jen that he should practice good
virtue and return all the things he has
stolen only then will the object stop
talking to him a while later the
repairmen are called and the car is
taken to the garage zhen wants it to be
repaired but the mechanic says that
replacing parts to such an old vehicle
is not possible so he should demolish it
after it is taken away zhen notices a
red mask on the road the mask talks to
him and informs him of four robbers who
are on their way to rob a jewelry shop
the scene shifts to a van where the said
robbers are driving to the set jewelry
shop one of them has lost his mask so
they kidnap a woman and use her tights
as a mask however when they reach the
shop the police are already there
waiting for them a few hours ago jen was
at the police station to inform the
police about the robbers that the mask
had told him about the police inspector
thought he was a freak at first but when
zhen communicated with his office table
he believed him that office table has
probably seen some after the
robbers are caught the police officer
asks jen to call his next of kin
believing him to be a mentally ill
person he calls kaume to the police
station who makes the police officer
understand that zhen is not in his right
mind they then go to the beach where
zhen tells her everything that has
happened to him until then kaumai
refuses to believe him and predicts that
he is suffering from schizophrenia she
says that she is ready to help him get
back to his normal mental state jen
agrees to act like he is mentally ill
hoping it will give him a chance to get
closer to kaume weird plan bro when she
leaves a lightning bolt strikes the park
bench he was sitting on seconds ago the
bench's human form chases zhen accusing
him of being the reason he was struck at
night jen goes to put the statue back in
the museum hoping that it will make him
go back to normal the human form of the
statue tells him that since he is doing
this for his own good it won't help him
still zhen keeps the statue in the
museum and leaves the next day brother
hey finds out that the statue was
returned by the thief he is being
pressured by his associates to get a
hold of the statue as soon as possible
because he has already accepted half of
the money meanwhile kaumei holds a
meeting with all the doctors of the
hospital including the former principal
to discuss jen's condition the doctors
however dismiss her concern saying that
zhen is faking his illness to get closer
to her except for the former principal
who supports her view and allows her to
help him at night zhen goes to an old
temple to return a book he had stolen he
sees a group of monks training but they
happen to be statues the chief monk
takes the book from him and praises jen
for doing the right thing the following
day kaumay brings him to a field when it
is about to rain she makes him wear an
antenna so the lightning bolt would
strike him again and cure his illness or
perhaps it will absolutely destroy him
however the plan doesn't work because
zhen is too scared to be struck on their
way back home zhen thanks kaume for
being nice to him when they were younger
it turns out that she was the only one
who believed him when the principal
accused him of stealing the money they
talk about a yellow umbrella that kaume
used to carry everywhere she claims that
it was her late mother's only memory but
someone stole it a few years ago she
curses the person who stole it not
knowing that it was actually zhen when
he reaches home he tries to talk to the
umbrella to apologize but it refuses to
talk to him following that he brings out
a painting from his stash of stolen
stuff
the painting happens to be the mona lisa
to check the authenticity of it he
brings it to a museum and shows it to
the artist adam adam is brother hayes
customer who has been pressuring him to
steal the statue he disguises his
illegal business using the art gallery
to jen's surprise cowmay is also at the
art gallery he finds out that she is
dating adam and leaves right after the
next day jen is in the hospital with
kaumei she has brought a lie detecting
machine wanting to check if he is really
telling her the truth as they talk she
asks him if he had a crush on her when
they were in school before zhen can
answer someone interrupts them a few
hours later jen goes to meet adam again
and finds him painting a nude picture of
a girl it is clear to him that adam is
cheating on cowmay zhen cannot sleep
that night he contemplates if he should
tell kaume the truth but his houseplant
advises him against ruining her
relationship later that day kaume takes
jen on a hot air balloon ride to help
him with his supposed fear of heights
she has also brought him a cake
remembering that it is his birthday jen
is overwhelmed by the gesture however
his happiness doesn't last long as on
their way back he hears her talk to adam
on the phone following that jen goes to
talk to adam about the original mona
lisa painting he owns but adam refuses
to believe him when he isn't looking
zhen takes the opportunity to text all
his flings on his phone the next day all
the girls including kaume gather and
beat adam up for playing them later that
day she goes to a club with jen to get
her mind off of her ex-boyfriend they
dance and drink the entire night jen
brings her to his house because she is
too drunk to drive home he quickly hides
the umbrella so she wouldn't see it and
they spend the rest of the night
watching tv in the meantime a jealous
atom goes to brother hey and shows him
cctv camera footage of jen talking to
his phone and asking for the passcode
adam has been keeping an eye on him for
the past few days and has found out
about his special power however brother
hay doesn't believe him back at jen's
home his belongings start to urge him to
tell kaume about the umbrella he gets
annoyed by them and goes to the dumping
site to meet his old car it is being
demolished so he wants to say his last
goodbye the man version of the car tells
him that it used to deliberately break
down when zhen went on a heist because
it is the only way the car could have
stopped him from doing bad things jen
apologizes for being rude to him for all
those years they share an emotional
goodbye as the man disappears into thin
air and the car is demolished following
the encounter jen goes to meet cow may
and tells her about his powers he also
hands her the yellow umbrella and
apologizes for taking it cowmay asks him
to talk to the umbrella and tell her
what her mother's last words were the
umbrella refuses to talk so kaume
doesn't believe him she storms off
furious at his lies after returning home
that day jen looks at his arm and sees
that the last line of the vein that was
red has turned normal meaning that all
his debts are paid and he can no longer
talk to things he gets a call from
brother hey threatening him with kaume's
life and asking him to come to a
warehouse zhen rushes there to find out
that hey wants him to talk to a locker
that contains valuable weapons and find
out its passcode if zhen fails to do so
he threatens to kill cow may she is hung
from a height on the other side of the
room zhen tries to communicate with the
locker but cannot he tells them that he
has lost his ability hey is about to
shoot him dead but the police arrive
just in time and save both of them when
zhen returns home he looks at his
belongings and reminisces about their
constant chattering the movie ends as we
see kaomei using her yellow umbrella to
protect jen from the rain
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching